nothing but illustrious guests here on
gamespot's play for all our charity
drive and gaming showcase for the summer
i'm really excited for this segment
because we have someone who
shaped the gears of war franchise and
who is now shaping the diablo franchise
rod ferguson executive producer on the
diablo franchise how are you doing man
i'm doing great thanks for having me i
really appreciate it yeah of course it's
it's uh it's been pretty wild to see
that that transition because we we know
we've been keeping up with your work uh
back when you were on gears but now
diablo is in such a
it's such a it's such a fascinating time
for the franchise because you have d4 we
have d2r
uh we have um immortals on uh on mobile
so
but i think let's get out of the way i
know you can't say much
but the folks need to know they're gonna
roast me if i don't ask you is there
anything you can share or update us on
with regards to diablo 4 yeah i mean you
know as we've been
since we did our announce uh the dev
team has been really focused on making
sure we're communicating with the
players
and so we've been putting out this
quarterly dev blog and we even had sort
of a
video one if you will or a visual one at
blizzcon recently
uh so our next one's coming so at the
end of this month we're gonna have our
new dev blog it's gonna be really
focused on character and character art
so we're really excited to share that
with players so that's that's the next
big thing from d4
all right sweet now we got that out of
the way we can focus on diablo 2
resurrected what are we here to talk
about i have no idea
oh wow peep the shirt so yeah we're here
to talk specifically about diablo 2
resurrected because
uh we are recording this before the xbox
showcase but
i'm not i'm going to ask you ahead of
time how does it feel to be on that
stage now
showing off what you're working on kind
of it is kind of weird though because
obviously gears is so tied to xbox and
now
that you're like yo i'm i'm with
blizzard now and you're back on the xbox
stage but
um how does it feel to represent diablo
on that stage now
yeah i mean no it's it's it's a little
surreal honestly like i was thinking
about that because i've been on
the actual stage at e3 a number of times
uh as part of being with microsoft and
uh this around this time we'd be like
you'd have had to go get your clothes
because you always have to buy a new
wardrobe to be on the stage
you'd be doing rehearsal after rehearsal
after rehearsal and just trying to make
sure that
you know what you had was going to be
great and and so it's been kind of funny
to
not have that process going on and not
being part of that anymore but
it's really exciting to be able to bring
something new to that i mean
diablo when you it's been traditionally
at least in a
long history especially in terms of
diablo 2 resurrected has been a pc only
kind of franchise for a while until
diablo 3 came to console
and and and i actually like it better on
console personally but
it's you know it's it's it's strong on
console there and so what i'm really one
of the things i'm really excited about
is being able to bring diablo 2
to a whole new audience a whole bunch of
players who never had necessarily
from an age perspective they may not
have been born when this game came out
yeah or
or they're just not pc gamers and they
didn't play it on pc and so
the fact that we're bringing this game
back in a really modern contemporary way
for new players on console
and we get to do that and announce our
ship date show off what the cinematics
look like and do that all on the e3
stages
well the virtual e3 stage is really
exciting so diablo 2 riders are
resurrected like you said is coming out
uh
september 23rd that's that's really soon
all things considered
and there's going to be a beta sometime
in august
and we've had the technical alpha which
i played a ton of
a lot of memories were unlocked uh
during
playing the technical alpha it was
really wild to see how much it's been
revamped
so since the technical alpha what kind
of
uh feedback have you seen what kind of
changes are you making as you
get much much closer to the actual
release date and
coming closer to a more open beta yeah i
mean it's been great it was one of the
things we really wanted to do was to
make sure that
we were having the game you know
available for player feedback we wanted
to hear what the players thought and
that was like that that single player
alpha was really a big moment for the
team because
you know we've been making certain
decisions around what do you keep parity
from the original and how what do you
improve and
you know we we're kind of making those
choices based on our philosophy and what
we think is the right choice and
when we put it out there for alpha we
got uh
people loved it it was it was the
response has been fantastic similar to
your response and
but we did get feedback which is great
and we're listening to that uh you know
as we look at
different things around big things
around hey this is
a little bit you know like for example
that you should spawn in before the load
screen is gone and so you can be killed
when you spawn in like that's a big
thing we have to fix that right and then
there's small things like hey i find the
lightning too thin or the blizzard isn't
blizzardy enough and so
you know it's it's it's a wide range of
feedback and we're able to
sort of focus on it and really listen to
what the players wanted
and we even took it a step further one
of the things i really wanted to do in
in the alpha is partner with ablegamers
and so we were able to get
disabled players to play as well and
give us feedback i mean it's hard when
it's a 21 year old game you're building
on top of you can't necessarily do
everything you want to do but
we just wanted to understand like are
there blockers or how can we help and
and so we've been really looking at what
we can do with that feedback as well
sweet that sounds that sounds great i
mean that kind of goes into my next
question too
is trying to determine what you can and
cannot change or
what you want and don't want to change
so kind of
how do you determine that as you like
you step into a new role you're
got your hands on something that is very
precious to a lot of players
yeah i mean our key word was
authenticity
like how do we keep the experience
authentic and so
there are things about the game that um
can make it challenging
in a good way for example you get a
quest and it doesn't tell you
now go here to do the quest like you
have to go and discover and explore and
we think that's a big part of the game
and then there's things like uh the fact
that you don't have a shared stash
amongst characters
means you have to create mule characters
and you're dropping stuff on the ground
and re-logging in really quickly and
it's in and it's not
it doesn't add to the experience it's
just part of what the technology was
like back 21 years ago so
we've been really focused on making the
game more accessible and that's from
you know how to play from those types of
things i just talked about the
workarounds that people had to do
from bringing it to console and even you
know some accessibility features as well
but
it would we really been focused on
parity and that's one of the nice things
is that
the original diablo 2 game that 2d
sprite based game
is underneath the covers it's the engine
that's driving all the gameplay
decisions
did you kill that monster did you get
that loot all that has been driven by
the original game
and what we've done is put a layer on
top of it which is this 4k
hd surround sound layer that sort of
takes all that sort of that engine and
represents it in a much higher fidelity
and so it's
so it has been tricky but we want to
bring quality of life we know that
people wanted things like a shared stash
or
and we know that they wanted things like
auto gold pick up the way a contemporary
game would
but there were other things that we were
just like oh that's a bridge too far
that's that's
simplifying the game not making it
easier to play like we want we want it
easier to play but not easy if you know
what i mean or easier
and so it's been a lot of that but how
we how we give people more access and
make it
and onboard them in a better way yeah i
think when i covered the technical alpha
i was like oh damn i got my ass kicked
uh
like i don't know how to control mobs
anymore like oh i forgot
how to do that and i learned real fast i
can't think of diablo 2
playing it any other than keyboard and
mouse and then with for d3
i can't imagine playing it other than
like a gamepad
and like those two games just like feel
so different in my mind and it really
stood out when i played uh the d2r um
technical alpha
but how have you adapted the core of
d2 onto a console experience because
there's a lot of
like you said the the basis of d2 is
still
that's still the core thing that's
running this game um but i can imagine
like things like inventory management
and how you like control mobs how you
uh fire off skills and get away and move
and pick things up in the environment
how have you like broadly like how have
you just made this a
a sensible console experience
yeah i mean you just it's basically a
focus on understanding what the console
and the controller is good at and
understanding that
again it's one of those things where we
try some things and we go
that's too far like we had for a while
when you plugged in a controller
your inventory auto sorted for you to
try to keep so you didn't have to do the
the inventory tetris and it was like oh
this kind of breaks the game this is
kind of part inventory tetris is part of
the game itself yeah
um and so finding creative ways to allow
you to
move things between let's say your
inventory and your belt or your
inventory and your stash and shortcuts
and
the way that it feels in terms of like
some skills are dependent like
sorcerer's teleport you know it depends
on where you click to
and so now we're having to sort of
predict you know a certain range of
distance and those sorts of things based
on
how you use the controller but it
fundamentally is just a change from
you're telling the you know the
character where to go to you are the
character
giving them you know that direction
through the sticks and
that was the the team um you know the
dev team just did a fantastic job it's
like
the very first time we implemented
controller support it was already very
playable and it felt
very it felt great to play as especially
as like i said
i'm similar to you like i play d3 on
gamepad mostly
and so i was kind of interested to be
like how does this gonna feel
to control because it's not built from
the ground up for this and so how how is
it going to work and
it feels great like especially like
ranged attacks feel really good melee
it's actually really good it's just
stuff like why
you know auto gold pickup works so well
it's like one of the things going in and
trying to identify every single piece of
gold and picking them up
you know with every button press was
just too much for like and
so there's certain things that get
turned on as an option now those things
you can turn off
and that's a lot of things that we did
too is like when we made a choice we
sometimes made it an option where
maybe somebody loves auto gold pickup
and maybe somebody doesn't and so they
can choose whether to turn it on or turn
it off
based on their playstyle but yeah it was
really just trying to make it
feel more native you know even though
that it wasn't and i could you don't
want it to feel like oh this is
a pc port and therefore it feels kind of
like
i don't know clunky and those sorts of
things and so we've dedicated a lot of
effort in trying to make that feel
smooth
and to feel like you have precision and
feel like you can do what you want to do
and it feels like a great console
experience moving to controller had it
uh any effect on how you perceive the
balance of certain classes
if at all no i mean it all i mean like i
said there are certain things where
you would have a certain precision about
where you could do
certain things but the same thing for
diablo 3 is that certain builds like
certain barbarian builds are easier with
mouse and keyboard than they are with
controller as an example so
one of the things we really because were
trying to deliver that authentic
experience we just didn't want to mess
with balance
that you know we know that there are
certain balance issues and potentially
like the
you know people call the hammered in
with the paladin with um
is is a strong character build currently
in the building but
that idea that we were changing a bunch
of things visually we didn't want to get
into changing the balance of how the
game
plays too because it felt a little too
risky and so
everything we did was very focused on
keeping the balance as it is
so this open beta that's coming up is
going to be the time you get to
kind of test out multiplayer because i
know technical alpha was uh
single-player only get our got our feet
wet there but
i'm kind of excited to jump back into d2
multiplayer i remember my friends back
in high school
doing a lot of they carried me often and
i expect them to do it again this time
around
um but yeah what can we expect from
the multiplayer aspects in the beta or
even the full game
yeah well i mean that's one of the part
of we're getting ready with september
23rd as our release date you know we're
going to do this august multiplayer beta
and it's really
you know you want to test out all the
systems we're going to this sort of
we're going to the battlenet you know
global battlenet servers and we're going
to have all these blizzard servers
running and we want to be able to see
okay let's put a large load on it let's
test our services let's test our servers
and get people playing that experience
they didn't get to play in the technical
alpha so
some great things that one is you know
obviously again the big difference is
multiplayer versus single player so the
beta is
unique for that and so you can either
bring people together and play co-op
up to eight people um or play pvp if you
want to
and then uh it's on console so this will
be the first time people get to
experience d2r on console which will be
a big moment
and uh and then we're expanding the
classes so we're allowing people to play
five classes instead of the three in
alpha so we've added the druid and the
paladin to the mix and so
again you can go in and play as a judo
paladin and and see how they play as
well
i've heard that you are a big fan of the
redone cinematics so
all of the cinematics have been like
revamped um
that's that's kind of why can you take
me behind the scenes in terms of
how the team did approach that or even
like just pulled it off
yeah i mean it was really around you
know when we look at the philosophy of
the game the philosophy is really about
it's a remaster not a remake like we
wanted
we're taking the purity and the
authenticity of the original and we want
to just
elevate it with you know with sort of 4k
art and the surround sound and such
and so but when we looked at the
cinematics like a lot of remasters will
take the cinematics and say oh let's
just upres them
or do something that because you don't
necessarily have the source material
anymore and you can't just kind of work
from what you had
years ago and we just felt like the when
you think about d2r
or d2 it it's such a genre defining game
and it had such a meaningful moment in
time 20 years ago that
we felt like it really deserved to have
the cinematics remade
and so we went into it going okay we
don't want to change how we tell the
story and we don't want to change
what the story is because people talked
about like oh could you shorten it or
could you give a different perspective
or could you and we're like no we want
to be
faithful to the source material but what
we want to do is bring it forward again
in a really
modern way and so we went in and worked
with we have a
story and franchise development team
called sfd and
blizzard that they're the ones who work
on all the amazing cinematics that
blizzard makes
and so we partnered with them and we
were able to work
with another partner called access i
don't know if you know of them but they
we i worked with them on gears of war as
well as part of our hive buster trailer
but they all came together and we're
going to remake this
shot for shot uh in the highest cg that
we can do in the time that we have and
make and
you get a taste of that in the trailer
you get to see little snippets of it and
i can't wait for people to see more
because it's everyone did a phenomenal
job you know like that
again i feel like it elevates d2r
because
the quality of the storytelling now that
you get all that detail
that you maybe didn't see before the the
were those beetles on the floor were
there spiders on the floor like no
they're beetles you know they're beetles
like i can see that detail and i can see
you know all the different things that
are happening and sort of the story
telling what's going on in the
environment and on the characters and
their faces
and their emotions that they're having
and so it's i love it and i think it
i think it really takes it to another
place i have one more question
and it's kind of a kind of a broad one
to hit to you but
uh you've moved to a blizzard fairly
recently and
it's still kind of wild to think that
you're that you are representing diablo
um now but what have been the biggest
changes going from
you know shaping gears of war and now
shaping diablo like
how you work what you work on the things
you focus on in game development how you
handle your teams what has changed for
you man
i think the the number one thing has got
to be the pandemic the
i only had eight days in office when i
first arrived and then we're all working
from home and where i'm
i'm used to being you know walking the
halls and standing up
in front of the team and and working
with people uh one-on-one and such
that that everything is through you know
a video camera now and uh
it's it's been surreal to do that and
i've i mean i've been with them now
15 months and it's like like i said
except for eight days it's all been
through
uh through a camera and so it's really
changed how i try to lead it changes how
i
communicate it changes a lot of things
and so it's also been interesting
because we're
with gears you know i i joined gears
back in 2005 and i was basically there
pretty much the whole way and i was kind
of the
the person who was the keeper of the
lore and the keeper of the franchise i
was the creative director of it
and so i was the one teaching and and
others were learning
and now i'm coming into a franchise that
i've loved you know
since the original d1 and and having
played it
for all this time but still you're
coming i'm coming in as a student that
i don't know all the lore and i don't
know every secret and everywhere every
skeleton is kind of
in their closet around you know like how
the game works in the way that certain
details about certain systems and
so i've had to come in much more as a as
a student of of
the game than i was when i was the head
of the coalition sort of running gears
of war so
that's been really interesting it's part
of what and you know it's what helped
inspire me to do this was just
it's a new challenge uh getting to work
on one of my favorite franchises
and getting to work with the caliber of
tell him i get to work out at blizzard
so
uh it's been interesting like i said
doing it
you know from my dining room in north
carolina as a strange place to be
to be trying to lead three diablo games
to ship but um
but it's been uh it's been exciting i
appreciate the time
that you gave to us to talk about diablo
and your work and your career
is there anything else that you want to
share before i let you go here well i
think the one thing that
i really want to call out too around the
beta is just that the pre-order is
happening so that's one of the big
things is that with our announcing our
ship date
uh at the e3 event we can now take
pre-orders for console
in terms of uh and what that also those
pre-orders allows you to get into the
open beta
sooner so we're actually going to do the
beta in two phases and so there'll be a
pre-order access phase and then an open
phase so i highly recommend and we're
also going to we have a really cool
if you pre-order the game you'll
actually get a transmog
in d3 that will allow you to change your
barbarian both male and female to look
like the diablo ii barbarian
which i think is really kind of cool to
have that iconic barbarian look in d3
um so that's coming and like i said and
getting access to the pre-order beta uh
would be a great time to get in and like
i said get to play the five classes get
to see the game
and uh get you have to play early with
your friends rod ferguson thank you so
much for your time man take care
uh and uh yeah diablo 2 resurrected it's
coming soon
uh y'all should peep that too and um
yeah thank you all for watching this
segment here on diablo 2 resurrected
i want you all to stick to gamespot.com
because we have so many more interviews
gameplay reveals trailers and live
streams because we are raising money for
ablegamers
and i hope to see you all around next
[Music]
time
[Music]
you